um hey mike
there's no such thing as alpha males and
adam ruins everything it's gonna tell
you why
this thing is this is a couple year old
video but i had never seen it i think
you're gonna enjoy it this is what
somebody who's not an alpha male says
yes
you make me laugh at him which is weird
because you're not really my type
which is weird because you're not funny
that is the gift haircut
well he's a guy in the history of
garrick and remember he's also the one
that was fighting with rogan about
giving hormones to babies and [ __ ] i get
that he's a good guy but even for a guy
that haircut
i usually go for alpha males that's not
weird at all
because in humans the very idea of the
alpha male makes absolutely no sense
well you're wrong and there absolutely
is uh
especially in mammals every mammal
does have alpha males we run in packs
and it happens now i'm not saying it's
the same as [ __ ]
lions where you have to kill somebody
but there is it's just like type a and
type b
personalities these are things that have
been measured you see uh we have what
you have to understand
is is that you have alphas and then
the gammas and the deltas and betas
in the omegas i don't know what do you
think an alpha male is
a confident assertive leader who knows
what he wants and
always gets his way you know somebody
who says things like
get swole and muscle milk and high i'm
vin diesel no but that's but again
that's that's not what an alpha male is
so you're already using an
incorrect idea of what an alpha that's a
meat head
alpha males don't have to be swollen and
ripped yeah alpha males wear
tap out and what get
bar fights for no reason and fight over
women they're not even with
all right enough about brian callan
let's come home let's
get to this oh so like this guy
what up freaks name's alpha adam i'm
confident straight up banging and if you
think women don't love me i'm going to
debunk the f out of that myth
that's not what being
an alpha male is uh
you baker
i'm bringing it back mike soy boy beta
[ __ ]
attraction to alphas is genetic comes
from nature i'm like the outside
the leader why does he have the don
flamenco
curl in the front of his hair rose in
his mouth that's
what what is this first off adam
you don't look like an alpha male you
look like a yeah honestly quite frankly
you barely qualify as looking at like a
male
seriously holy [ __ ] man
you're like you're like internet james
gordon like that's what you are
[Music]
hell yeah i'm bleeding well all of that
is wrong
because alpha will because i'm gonna
pull this is i haven't
i haven't seen this whole video but adam
ruins everything goes through a same
through the same thing every time the
sources that he pulls from are like
slate or a vice opinion piece
i like that he's like all right now i'm
really going to blow your minds
real alpha males have stomachs full of
[ __ ] and like to stick their pee pee
where the poopoo comes out
what so like brian cowan you're just
it's just circling back around to brian
gallon
wolves don't exist in fact the term
alpha wolf was disavowed by the very
scientists who popularized it
the story starts in 1977
while doing research in a national park
a wildlife biologist named l david meach
seemed to observe that one wolf emerges
the dominant male
one wolf is the dominant leader the big
wolf at least coke logic is getting work
daddy it's adonis paul alpha wolf
he wrote a book on the idea and it
became a media sensation
alpha wolves are real and i love them
and i bet humans are like this too
it's real life but twenty years later
me tried to people you know the only
thing adam ruins is women's sex drives
in the wild and when he did he realized
he had made a terrible mistake
those aren't dominant wolves those are
mummies and daddies
wolves don't have an alpha hierarchy at
all they're just parents
but they do and so do lions and so do a
lot of creatures
they do they absolutely do when there's
when there's a when there's a group of
people
men or women but there was when there
was a group of people right
when there's it's been studied several
several times
remember when they did and it was really
unethical but it was like getting in the
60s they did that prison experiment
yeah yeah and they gave all the airmen
uh herpes and syphilis
and then uh you know because they were
black yeah enough about brian callan
um what the [ __ ] is everything i don't
know
i don't know i don't know what i have
from today but they did that experiment
where they made half of the students
uh be be like guards
and the other half were prisoners right
oh yeah and then the ones that were
guard just became total sociopaths right
exactly
it does people will rise up on the ranks
and people will take charge
if there's a group if in a survival
situation usually one person will be
like okay look hey
here's what we need to do this is what
we're doing
that's what an alpha male is it is a
real thing that occurs
it's not people that are crushing
[ __ ] rippets you know and
rods i must alert the masses stanford
prison experiment thank you scarface to
renounce the term alpha wolf
and spent years trying to get his own
book taken off the shelves
stop reading this i vent you lies alpha
wolves aren't real
but it was too late the term had taken
on a life of its own
and we haven't stopped using it since
so alpha wolves are just parents huh
i guess my therapist was right i really
do have daddy issues no no
maybe there's no alpha wolves but i know
crap too alpha that's weird then how
come naturally women
seem to be attracted more to men that
are can be
providers and can protect them why is
that if this isn't real right
why aren't women attracted to uh to to
little little [ __ ] manlets that could
do nothing
you mean like adam right yeah like adam
exactly they end up going for a brian
cowan type
sorry i'm all for it
you don't have to sell me but quit
digging you're already struck
[ __ ] the males are found in chimps our
closest genetic relatives that's right
real alpha males get divorced leave
their kids behind and put shoes on a
table
what like brian
weird you are more aggressive than me
but also wronger
first of all chimps aren't our closest
genetic relatives
bonobos are and bonobos live in a
matriarchal society
excuse me you're in my way
but a man could beat all those women
well not adam but a real man could beat
all those women up
you're basic except for the black one
whatever you're right well
said women those bonobo broads don't
mean nothing in chimps the alpha male is
the most dominant most aggressive bro
yeah they are dare i say kalanesque
in their sports ball and puss crushing
abilities
first access to food resources and of
course
mates hell yeah baby all right
not exactly contrary to popular belief
in chimps the most aggressive male
doesn't always become the leader
smaller more mild-mannered males can
actually become dominant by doing favors
and
could you get a better like could you
get a more attractive girl for this too
i mean look adam's trying as hard as he
can okay no the other one
oh obsessively grooming other chimps
excuse me you seem to have something in
your hair thanks
oh hey let me ask you what do you think
i should do with my life
wait whoa what am i doing get off of me
i am the strongest most what's the point
of this
this is this is a loser
trying to just trying to justify that
women should go out with losers but he's
the thing with reality right
in reality this isn't what happens
you could have your little [ __ ] show
and your little college humor which is
now defunct
it shows on true tv now or whatever
comes on after practical jokers
uh you could have your [ __ ] your
little show and you could do all this
but
reality is reality right like you ask
women yes sure
women online why do you see it all the
time women will be like can i just find
i
wish i could find a caring guy that
listened to me but they all date drug
dealers
you know [ __ ] drug dealers and beat
them up that's just because
in nature women are attracted to even
you read about women in their cycle
right depending on what part of their
cycle they're in
they're attacked attracted to different
type of men you know when like they're
ovulating they're attracted to more
aggressive guys that are going to be
able to protect them and [ __ ] that's how
it is
i also why on the alpha now and forever
no
you're not unlike chimps human social
hierarchies are constantly in flux
so wait a second isn't it funny
i i always find this funny isn't it
funny for these evangelical atheists
because adam is one of those evangelical
atheists right
when it comes to evolution we came from
monkeys man
darwinism dude but then when you try to
use that same
mentality okay fine you know we came
from bonobos we came from men
for monkeys relax caveman exactly then
you're like uh we're nothing like
animals
in this scenario except we're making fun
of christians
then we're all just animals they just
cherry picking
this is adam cherry picks facts to
[ __ ] get what he wants exactly
so you might be the dominant male here
but if you were playing dungeons and
dragons
it's your turn hello but the people
playing no one playing dungeons and
dragons
is a dominant male well except the the
dungeon master
no do you know what's the dominant male
dungeons and dragon the monster the word
masters right in there
the mom who brings him the pizza rolls
ah actually you know you know what who
is actually the alpha in uh dungeons and
dragons
brian ryan [ __ ] brian calling again
what do you want to do
i attack with my sword your sword you
are a
magic user dude yeah cool and now if you
were a real alpha male you'd [ __ ]
every girl there because let me tell you
even the girl the girls that hang out
with these dungeons and dragon dudes you
know who they [ __ ]
guys that don't play dungeons and
dragons that's how it is
dude go to a [ __ ] back in the long
long ago we used to go to these
cons you know to uh comic cons and stuff
like the cover
cover stuff and the girls that are
playing magic the gathering
are not [ __ ] the dudes that are
playing magic the gathering no no of
course not i
i actually went to one of those places
one time you know like the
the stores well they sell those
tabletops right right
and they have tournaments in the stores
yeah and i went with a girl one time
named cat who i was
like fooling around with at the time and
uh she was like
she was a weird chick man because she
was a stripper but she was like into
nerdy [ __ ]
so i went with her one night and bro
i swear to god dude the amount of death
stares
like i was the most despised person
that ever walked through those doors oh
yeah because she'd been going there for
a while and all these little
all these little nerdy guys were like
[ __ ] in love with this chick
and then i just rolled in with it when i
[ __ ] smell like weed
going like what's this nerd game that
you nerds play remember
remember the clip that we that the
cousin joe when cousin joe went to the
comic con
because oh a cousin dance co-host oh
yeah
when he went to the comic con and he was
just hitting he
see this oh yeah that was great he was
just hitting on all these chicks
and there were he dude he got numbers he
[ __ ] one of them like and these chicks
all these whisper [ __ ] brian
might be listening oh okay good so i
don't know why the white rice just did
he's like yeah dude even like [ __ ]
okay you're right
do you see a sword on your character
sheet no well then you can't attack with
a sword can you freak
unlike animals no one is the same type
of person in all situations
human society is much more complicated
than that
so we have by your very logic
you're proving the religion and the
divine spark
right so you're saying that we are
different than animals therefore our
life is more valuable than animals
therefore abortion is wrong no
no no i'm i'm following his logic am i
wrong by following
his logic we're not like animals
well you're a racist nazi so no
okay just saying you're right you know
who are alpha males
soldiers so to say that this guy
is an alpha male or that guy's a beta
male makes straight
up zero cents but calling everybody a
bigot
for not wanting to give hormones to
babies that
straight up makes total sense also i
found me
why why are all the it just seems like
you're a beta male trying to make up the
thing
there are no beta metals you know what i
mean
it's like there's no winners or losers
bro it's like when i wrote this on
twitter the other day
last night i wrote uh you know comedy is
a subjective
and then the quote was by dude who sucks
at comedy
because it's always like there's always
this excuse nah man beta males don't
even exist
we're all like one [ __ ] species man
and you're like
you're beta male aren't you you know
it's like the same guy goes ah
you know what plenty of fish in the sea
right
who cares about these yeah i don't care
about these broads and it's like
you just got dumped didn't you you just
got shot down yeah you did
whatever nerd the most aggressive male
gets the most aggressive tail it's true
forever because it rhymes
actually research shows that
agreeableness kindness and generosity
are among the strongest indicators of a
long happy relationship
okay but they're cheating on you though
i mean i get it but that's what's
happening this is the same guy
that would tell you oh actually we
shouldn't be a monogamous relationship
this
i guarantee i haven't looked this up but
i guarantee you
that adam has and adam ruins everything
about monogamous relationships which
would
contradict the point that he's making
now right
guaranteed he has something like that
oh eat my feet those are beta traits oh
well then i guess bettas are the alphas
of love
what what's the matter royce betas
are the alphas of love this is all
beta talk sounds like that sounds like a
dashboard confessional song
sounds like the [ __ ] just
rationalizing [ __ ] over here
[Laughter]
enough lies i am the alpha i am your god
leave beta adam alone okay well that's
assault
first off and you would go to jail for
that that's that is an
aggressively obvious me also just
adam is fine and i'm not really into
chicks so i i hate this man